Aaron Sampson here to talk about the
Warlock class in the destiny beta so you
fired up to destiny beta lately shot
some doug's knife some nights in the
forehead but there's just something
missing from your life could it be magic
yes it's it's magic the Triwizard
champion of the Guardian world is the
warlock who is indeed a space wizard not
only a space wizard but according to the
grimoire and I'm paraphrasing here a
deep mother who contemplates the
traveler and then regurgitates that
knowledge in the form of purple
whoop-ass you will begin your year one
journey as the void Walker and by the
time you cap out at level 8 in the beta
you will still be a void Walker at level
15 in the full release of the game
you'll be able to become a son singer
which can buff themselves and burn stuff
down okay back to the beta the void
Walker specializes in hit-and-run
tactics being the class least capable of
sustaining a fight at point-blank range
this is accomplished using their vortex
grenade special Nova bomb and facepalm
melee attack ending a damaged train with
the upgraded energy drain version of the
facepalm attack not actually called
facepalm attack will reduce your grenade
cooldown time special armor such as the
chrome eval 3 helmet and gauntlets add
to your discipline skill which further
reduces your grenade cool down so with
the right combo say grenade shoot face
bomb you can have another grenade
rearing to go in short order also our
advice is to skip that first scatter
grenade upgrade since its increased
damage area is not really worth the
reduced damage done the specialty piece
a wizard gear carries is the bracelet
also known as the potential bond heavy
emphasis on the potential and potential
bond since at this point in the beta it
doesn't seem to do anything once you've
got a grasp on your gear and skills it's
time to think more about guns
sure you could roll with the giant 48
round carrying an auto rifle but is that
really Wizarding of you know what you
need is a proper one a wand with a core
consisting of hollow-point bullets what
you need sir is a hand cannon the hand
cannon is designed to drop massive
damage in the form of head shots which
fit sportingly with the hit-and-run
style of the Warlock for your special
weapon you should roll with a fusion
rifle that shoots magic or lasers and
quickly annihilates small groups of
low-level enemies or gets rid of one
particularly nasty one think of it as
your best line of defense when
backpedaling from invisible sword
wielding elites or not elites
alternatively if you want to do as much
damage as possible before going in on
your foes and just pack a Pompeii lr3
sniper rifle it fits your Wizarding
lifestyle because it does fire damage
and that is elemental to success haha
finally in the heavy weapons category
you should forego the rocket launchers
and roll with the machine gun remember
the run part of hit-and-run if you find
yourself surrounded by unfriendlies pull
the trigger on this bad boy and don't
stop till it goes click so in conclusion
the warlock class should hang back and
take care of business from cover only
going in to finish bows at the last
possible second with a stiff arm a smart
wizard equip specialty armor to get
their vortex grenade back up and running
as fast as possible make sure also to go
up and frequent our vendors in order to
pick up extra ammo which you'll need if
you plan to take on hard missions also
completing the level 6 strike in the
beta will net you a special wizard
speeder bike which is kind of cool what
are your warlock tips and tricks are you
a hit-and-run type the hang back and
snipe type or something else altogether
let us know your best tactics in the
comments below until then we'll be sure
to work our magic through the power of
interpretive dance in
Maria's places instead
you